Westworld season 2 is full of flashbacks
and time twists that make it hard to
tell what's happening let's figure out
the timeline from the beginning about 35
years ago Ford and Arnold created West
world and the hosts
they got investment from Logan the son
of James Telus after arnold son Charlie
died Arnold worked with a host to Loras
to bring her to consciousness which is
symbolized by the maze but Arnold
realized that conscious hosts would
suffer in the West world park so he
tried to stop the park opening by making
Dolores kill the hosts and himself the
host acacia to have found Arnold's maze
in the aftermath which started his own
path to consciousness at some point Ford
and Dolores created but not a host based
on Arnold despite Arnold's death Ford
opened the park anyway a few years later
Logan brings William to the park William
falls in love with Dolores but then
turns to violence and darkness becoming
the man in black William leaves Logan in
the desert and he and James invest more
in West world William builds the forge
in the valley beyond this place records
data on West world guests so that they
can decode the human mind and make
immortal copies of people William
marries James's daughter Juliet and
takes over the Telus company Logan falls
out with his father James and later dies
of an overdose when James dies they make
an immortal copy of him though in a
physical body he keeps breaking down so
all of this happens in the past the 30
years later season 1 happens after
Juliet commits suicide
William visits the Della's clone one
last time then enters the park and kills
Maeve and becomes obsessed with the maze
but the maze is about host consciousness
so Dolores awakes by remembering her
past Maeve awakes and decides to find
her host daughter West world executives
Teresa and Charlotte try to take power
from Ford Charlotte puts a key to the
forge inside the host Peter Abernathy
and in the season 1 finale
Dolores starts a robot uprising she
kills Ford but Ford knew this would
happen and has Bernard make a digital
backup copy
afford that's season 1 season 2 has two
timelines most of the season happens
before the flooding of the valley but
there's also the stuff after the flood
with but not on the beach and Carl
strand everything else is mostly
straightforward so Dolores fights a war
on humans and hosts william faces his
past and ends up killing his daughter
emily a cachito leads hosts to the door
to the sublime digital paradise for
hosts Maeve goes to Shogun world and
gets her daughter into the sublime
perform a if is killed Bernard gets
caught up with Charlotte looking for
Abernathy then he and Elsie find James
Delos and the copy of Ford gets in
Bernards head for a bit
Delores attacks the Mesa and gets the
Abernathy key so she goes to the forge
with Bernard and uses its data to learn
about the human mind
Delores starts the big flood and tries
to destroy the forge and the sublime
so Bernard kills her but then Bernard
helps Delores by putting her mind inside
a copied body of Charlotte
Bernard scrambles his own memories to
hide the truth lies on the beach and
wakes up in episode 1 the other timeline
so strand looks for Abernathy with
Charlotte who by then is actually
Dolores so when Charlotte finds out that
Bernard is a host and torches him that
Charlotte is Dolores call her char Loras
the humans drain the valley and return
to the forge we're sure Laura skills
strand she decides to help the hosts in
the sublime by satellite transferring
them somewhere safe then Dolores kills
Bernard and takes his brain and others
out of West world in Arnold's old house
Dolores recreates her own body and
Bernards and plans to take over the real
world back in the park
William is still alive but in some far
future timeline we see a copy of bill go
down an elevator into the old ruined
Forge and meets a hosts version of Emily
this William is trapped in a loop a
prison of his own sins so that's what
happens in West world but what does it
mean we'll answer that in a new video
coming soon
last episode West world referenced
slaughterhouse-five a story that's all
so about a guy called bill who questions
freewill and is lost in a twisted
timeline this book is tragic and weird
and hilarious and you can listen to it
for free today by signing up for a trial
at audible.com slash ASX members get a
free book each month and if you cancel
you keep the books they've got all the
great Vonnegut's and even some Plutarch
who's also referenced last episode so
get as well read as the man in black and
help out old ship decks by signing up at
audible.com slash ASX
or text ASX to 500 500 thanks for
watching and thanks to the patrons
including Amanda Crabtree Byron Elton
Josh shank Brandon Burt and Skadden
Cheers
you